- This video is brought
to you by Dashlane.
You hear on TV a lot that there's
no such thing as collusion.
- Sitting here looking
into the federal code
trying to find collusion as a crime.
- It's not.
- Collusion is not a crime.
- The Trump Tower meeting was not a crime,
it was not collusion.
- Collusion is not a crime.
- And it's true.
You can look through the entire US code,
and not find a single
crime called collusion.
And while that's true, that
misses the point entirely.
That isn't the end of the inquiry,
that is the very beginning.
Collusion is a shorthand.
And what people mean
when they use that term
is actually much, much worse.
(gavel bangs)
Hey LegalEagles, welcome
back to Lawsplainer,
where we explain the most important
legal concepts of the day.
Don't forget to subscribe
and hit that bell for more
legal explanations, and of course leave
your comments in the form of objections.
Today, we're talking about collusion.
What is it?
What is it not?
And what do people actually
mean when they refer
to the broad rubric of collusion?
What crimes may fit under that umbrella?
Now, to understand what collusion is,
I have to give yo a little
background on the nature
of a criminal conspiracy
and accomplice liability.
Because people often use
the terms conspiracy,
collusion, and aiding and
abetting or accomplice
liability almost interchangeably.
They're actually very different things
and have very different implications.
First, what is a conspiracy?
A conspiracy is an agreement by two
or more persons to commit a criminal act.
That agreement can be
explicit or can be implicit,
that's not actually
have to be written down
in some sort of contracts somewhere.
And generally, a
conspiracy does not require
an overt act, just an agreement to engage
in some sort of criminal act.
Unlike aiding and abetting
which we'll get to in just a second.
Now it's really important for
the purposes of this collusion
discussion is that under federal law,
a party to a conspiracy is responsible
for any criminal act
committed by a co-conspirator,
so long as that act falls within
the scope of the conspiracy
or is a foreseeable
consequence of that conspiracy.
So if you enter into a criminal
conspiracy, you can be held
liable for any of the acts
of your co-conspirators,
regardless of whether you
did the thing in question.
Now a similar but different concept
in criminal law is called
accomplice liability,
commonly called aiding and abetting.
Aiding and abetting does not require
any kind of agreement,
only that the accomplice
commit or attempt to commit some act
with the intent of
furthering the primary crime.
And that includes, for
example, buying a gun
and giving it to a bank robber
in furtherance of a bank heist.
But it also includes post crime conduct,
like helping the robber get away
or hiding evidence of the crime itself.
And sometimes, even offering encouragement
counts as an act in
furtherance of the crime
sufficient to create accomplice liability.
Even attempted aid, even
if it's not successful,
is usually enough in most jurisdictions
to be guilty of the primary crime.
But both conspiracy
and aiding and abetting
require an underlying crime.
You can't convict someone of a conspiracy
unless they conspired
to do something illegal.
And you can't aid and abet something
that is totally legal.
But where there is
underlying criminal conducts,
generally, the conspirators
and the accomplices
are as guilty as the person
who pulls the trigger itself.
So even if the members of
the Trump administration
were not the gunman, so to speak,
they can still be held
liable if they engage
in a conspiracy to commit
some sort of criminal act
or aided and abetted some criminal act
and acted in furtherance of that.
But for liability to attach
in the context of collusion,
there still must be an
original illegal predicate act.
So what could those predicate acts be?
Well based on public
reports, there's actually
a long list of things that may potentially
give rise to criminal liability.
The first is potentially
aiding and abetting
or conspiracy to conduct computer crimes.
This is generally speaking all
of the hacking related activities.
There's a whole raft of potential crimes
under the Computer Fraud
and Abuse Act among others,
including accessing private information,
trespassing on computers,
and peddling stolen data.
This could apply if anyone actually helped
the hackers break into the
Democratic National Committee,
or if anyone helped out those hackers
after the deed was
done, that could qualify
as either a conspiracy
or aiding and abetting.
(beeping)
- [Child] Salutations, hacker.
Would you like to disrupt democracy?
Enjoy your stay.
(criminal screams)
- In addition, all of
these acts could qualify
as a conspiracy to
defraud the United States,
which reaches financial and property loss
through the use of a scheme
or artifice to defraud,
but it's also designed
and intended to protect
the integrity of the United States,
its agency's programs and policies.
Some of what is alleged
might qualify as bribery
of officials or individuals.
There may be a fair amount
of money laundering going on
from foreign governments
or foreign officials.
There are allegations that
people who are not allowed
to bring money into United
States may have done so
through intermediaries like
the National Rifle Association
or through potential
real estate transactions
where oversight is minimal.
So if there was illegal money funneled
into the United States and
there was a failure to pay
the correct taxes on it, which could
give rise to federal tax evasion claims,
but also similarly state
tax evasion claims,
because the state governments
tend to tax exactly
the same things that the federal
government taxes as well.
These allegations might also give rise
to a conspiracy to commit election fraud,
including illegal
solicitation of donations
above federal limits.
Individuals and corporations paying
more than allowed under
campaign finance laws,
which is also a campaign
finance violation.
It appears that there
is very strong evidence
of foreign influence on the election
through fraudulent news
stories and social media posts.
There may be a conspiracy to engage in
and cover up campaign finance violations,
apart from just the monetary ones,
including in-kind donations
where the president
may have received something of value
that wasn't actual money,
like a friend buying
and killing potentially
harmful tabloid stories.
There could be wire and mail fraud.
Of course, hiding in plain sight
may be the president's
emoluments violations,
by virtue of the fact that
he's operating a business
that receives millions of dollars in funds
from foreign nationals
and foreign governments.
There are the Logan Act and FARA claims
on the basis that several
members of the Trump campaign
engaged in foreign influence peddling
without registering as a foreign agent.
Then there are the whole raft of crimes
that may have been
conducted in conjunction
with the investigation
into the original crimes,
which include things like
obstruction of justice,
perjury, making false statements,
and witness tampering,
which may be evidenced by
President Trump's own tweets
where arguably he was trying to influence,
intimidate, or impede
witnesses who either have
already given testimony
or will give testimony
in the Mueller investigation.
And on top of that, there is
a potential RICO violation.
I've handled a few RICO claims,
and I usually tend to agree
with Ken White, @Popehat,
who says that it's never ever RICO.
Except that this is a possibility
for a RICO claim here.
We'll see how it unfolds, but
RICO is incredibly complicated
and usually unnecessary,
especially given the dozens
of crimes that we have
already talked about
which may give rise to conspiracy
or accomplice liability.
So while it's true that there is
no such thing as the crime of collusion,
what's actually out there
is much, much worse.
Now, the US election infrastructure
may be woefully unprotected, but at least
you can be safe from computer crimes
thanks to Dashlane's
identity theft protection.
Dashlane protects your
identity across the Internet
by providing a tool that
generates strong passwords,
stores and auto-fills them securely
everywhere across the Internet,
seamlessly through all of your devices.
It's also a VPN which
acts as an intermediary
to make sure that all
of your Internet traffic
is encrypted, even when
you're on public Wi-Fi.
Because the Russians are out there.
Or maybe it was just a
400 pound hacker in bed.
Try Dashlane for free for
30 days at the link below,
and LegalEagles will get
10% off Dashlane Premium
by using the code below at checkout.
So click on the link,
prevent hacks, and protect
your identity from collusion
with Russian hackers.